the u.n security council has held an
emergency session to discuss the
taliban's restrictive policies on women
in afghanistan the uk envoy said it was
wrong and regressive that the hardline
group had banished women to the
sidelines of life the taliban scabs
range from prohibiting women from
traveling without a male chaperone
cutting them off from most employment
and banning older girls from going to
school measures designed to erase women
from public life the latest of these
dictates requires women to cover
themselves from head to toe
burka is not my identity
these afghan women chant it
asking for justice under the taliban
route takes a lot of courage but the
latest order for them to wear a complete
hijab meaning to cover up everything but
their eyes has anguished them once again
we want to live as living beings live as
noble creatures not to live as a captive
in one corner of the house not to be
held in the cage of our house and our
husbands go and back for food we never
want a day like this
like these usually won't last long
get out of here or i'll kill you this
armed law enforcer says
most of the women and girls have no
choice but to comply with the
restrictions the harshest since the
taliban came to power in august 2021
just a month after the takeover the
regime replaced the women's ministry
with the ministry of virtue and vice
women and girls have been told to stay
home
in the third quarter of 2021 their
employment levels fell by an estimated
16 percent much more than men
in december the taliban bent
long-distance travel for women without a
closed male relative
all of these happened while the de facto
authorities say they have changed
we have made progress in administration
in politics
in the development sector of the country
and in interaction with the nation
and the world
with each passing day
in all walks of life
we will gain more experience
and make more progress
progress is not what these girls
experienced
the taliban promised they could return
to secondary school in march
but they were sent home instead
a u-turn in policy that confirmed to
these girls that the taliban is
determined to strip them off their basic
rights
and joining me now from washington dc is
the u.s special envoy for afghan women
girls and human rights reena amiri
welcome mr miri the taliban continued to
issue draconian dictators curtailing
women's freedoms in afghanistan in your
assessment is the situation for women
and girls going to keep getting worse
well first thank you for having me on
and putting a spotlight on this really
critical issue
and unfortunately what we're seeing is
an expanding set of restrictions on
afghan women and it's quite systematic
um and it's it's certainly not looking
good as as one as one afghan woman
characterized it to me she said that she
had a sense that there was a taliban war
on women um and the this i think is is
something to to really take stock of is
that women in afghanistan feel under
siege by by the de facto authorities in
afghanistan
so how can you or the united states end
this siege
well we've made our
position emphatically clear that the
issue the situation of afghan women and
girls and human rights is of critical
importance to us
the taliban have consistently said that
they no longer want to be a pariah uh
be seen as a pariah by the international
community they want to have a
relationship with the international
community where they're seen as as
respected counterparts and we have said
that so long as you continue to behave
in the same way that you did as the
1990s there's going to be no change in
our relationship and moreover
the uh you know there's many things that
the taliban want they want
greater economic engagement they want
greater normalization they want more
diplomatic engagement all of that is
contingent on their behavior and what
they do in regard to women girls and the
human rights situation in afghanistan
they know that yet they keep
walking back on commitments that they
had made before they took over a rule in
their country i mean the majority of
women still can't work they can't travel
without male guardians secondary
education is a no-go do the taliban
really care
the taliban should care not just because
of the international community but
because they cannot hold the peace they
cannot prevent further brain drain in
afghanistan uh they cannot make
afghanistan
an economically viable country
and prevent further economic collapse
when they when they deny 50 of the
population their rights
now on monday state department spokesman
ned price said the u.s has caught a
number of tools it can use if the
taliban don't undo some of their recent
decisions concerning women
what are these tools
we are we've had
ongoing conversations discussions with
the taliban and at a working level we
continue to engage them and to make very
clear that they are there are a set of
uh demands on the on the side of the
taliban there are things that they would
like to have happen and for that the
role of the us and the international
community are key
um they understand that and we as i said
we've made it explicit those are the uh
i'm sorry to interrupt man but they
don't seem to be listening they seem to
be hearing you but they don't seem to be
acting on it which is why you have one
decision after another so they know they
want recognition and they need to do a
certain number of things to get it but
they still
continue with these draconian dictats
unfortunately what appears clear is the
taliban are prioritizing
their internal cohesion over the uh the
fate of the uh the country of the fate
of the population and their relationship
with the international community
they are making decisions that i think
will end up
costing them significantly on many
different levels
now uh last year in an um interview in
september you had said that afghan women
feel uh caught a profound sense of
betrayal
uh after the u.s withdrawal from the
country
given that is what they feel in your
words should afghanistan's women and
girls expect anything at all from the
united states
well i would note that one of the uh in
response to
the concerns heard from afghan women and
you know many and at that point i was an
independent actor when i made those
comments in response to to that concern
the us government established my
position and my office
and has
provided a a
i think significant support to my office
to uh to address this issue um so i
think that the commitment is certainly
there i've been in my position for five
months and i've seen that throughout the
government there is uh broad-scale
support for my efforts to uh to advance
the situation of women and girls
all right we leave it there for today
thank you so much for joining us irina
amiri the u.s special envoy for afghan
women girls and human rights thank you
so much
thank you
some afghan women are trying to fight
back 20 female lawmakers have set up a
parliament in exile in greece they
escaped to the capital athens when the
taliban seized power last august they
are determined to use their influence
and experience to help the women left
behind in their homeland
three years ago nazifa yusufi beck was
elected to the afghan parliament now the
politician has been forced into exile in
athens she says there's so much she'd
wanted to get done
i got up every morning with the will and
the gold to fight for afghan society and
for women's rights
those efforts were brutally interrupted
when the taliban seized power last
august
crowds besieged kabul airport desperate
to leave the country yusufy beck was
among them she knew that if she didn't
leave afghanistan the taliban would hunt
her down
she escaped with her children but that
deeply scarred her
when we got here we had lost everything
we had to leave our family behind my
parents all of our belongings
i was in bad shape traumatized
but i kept forcing myself to hope
now we're doing much better in greece
but the poor people back in afghanistan
things are quite bad
every day yusufi beck talks to her
family and friends back home
she was shocked when one day after the
afghan new year in march she heard that
the taliban had broken their promise to
allow girls to go back to school
the girl she's chatting to here had been
desperate to return to a classroom she
was just about to graduate
we hope that the women who are now
abroad will fight for us and try to find
a way for us to go back to school
and they are yusufi beck is not alone in
athens
shagufa norzai is one of many other
afghan lawmakers in exile in the city
together with her former colleagues
norzai wants to fight for afghan women
from here the old greek parliament
today 24 ex-lawmakers are meeting here
to form a new parliament a parliament in
exile and a female one
before the taliban invasion there were
69 women lawmakers in afghanistan
now not a single woman is in government
and the legislature has been abolished
shagufa norzai starkly warns the west
over officially recognizing the
women taliban increase
intelligence will leave afghanistan
we will not have individual freedom
everyone who was busy with the religious
extremists i am
speaking from brussels member of the
european parliament hannah neumann
shares that view
dialogue with the taliban should
continue but the west should also take
this exiled parliament seriously
the lawmakers here will need such
backing to give a voice to people in
their homeland
afghans who could not leave the country
and now have to live under the taliban